the latest on the pandemic many
hospitals across the country are at a
breaking point more than 95 percent of
icu beds are occupied at one in four
hospitals nationwide according to the
new york times omar villafranca is in
hard hit memphis tennessee omar good
morning good morning here's a stat for
you tennessee leads the nation to the
number of new coveted cases per capita
that's according to the cdc and one of
the reasons why is the low vaccination
rate amongst kids for children between
the ages of 12 and 17 fewer than one in
four have been vaccinated and as the
doctors at le bonner children's hospital
can tell you that's having very
devastating effects
most 17 year olds do not request to go
to a doctor yeah which should have been
my first red flag it was late july when
julie mcdivitt's son jacob rodriguez
started feeling sick i felt like i had
covet
felt really tired had a
couldn't taste nothing it was
awful even after a positive test
mcdivitt expected her son a passionate
high school football player to run right
over covet and for a little while he did
when did it change
so day two fever hits and it never let
up 14 days straight he ran fever finally
mcdivitt got jacob into le bonner
children's hospital in memphis nurse
comes in and he's like looks like
jacob's played four quarters of football
with no pads on on the inside of his
body when you hear that from a medical
professional
what are you thinking
truthfully
god where are you taking us with this
you know
am i going to be on that list of numbers
is my kid going to be one of those
numbers jacob had developed severe
inflammation from miss c a rare and
potentially fatal condition related to
covid19 and for four days he and his
mother sat together in a hospital room
jacob slowly improved but over the
course of those four days laboner went
from treating five pediatric covet
patients to 21 within a few weeks it
peaked at 33 patients at least three
children died during the month of august
we had a perfect storm the vaccination
rate the delta variant and school
starting back dr nick highsmith is
medical director of infection prevention
at le bonner not only is it devastating
to see a child in that situation but to
know that the majority of this to this
point is preventable is also devastating
we didn't wear a mask like probably
should have been
was he vaccinated he was not were you
vaccinated i'm not but jacob's bowel
with the virus has changed things
mcdivitt says she's got plans to see her
doctor about the shock are you closer
i'm getting it i just have some
questions first people were just coming
up to me like every class period like
what'd you go through it's
no joke and i was telling them about it
like take this more serious or you could
probably end up like how i ended up
jacob lost 20 pounds and that's a big
deal for a young football player and he
also missed a few games of his senior
year but we want to show you some video
he made it back onto the field that was
him on friday actually running out there
with his teammates he told us he does
want to get the shot and after
everything he went through gail he told
us that some of his teammates
even got vaccinated after seeing him in
the hospital
i do like hearing that i'm sorry they
had to go through that to get the
message but glad jacob's going to be
okay thank you omar thank you very much